and how are you hi actors always go
tater yeah that's how you know you're
not doing well in the business and like
if I do like a morning showing they like
comedian Jim Norton
they have to say you're a comedian no
one gives a [ __ ] your wife the character
on house of cards was beautiful and re
but I'd like to meet her
yeah um is she married I don't know I
don't know you're trying to ask him did
Stevie what he was with Robin right okay
so she Robin Wright was my wife and so
in my mind so Jodi have you had an
interview where are nobody tried to get
you to set your costume designer on that
movie show business movie hey your TV
wife can you hook me up with but you do
though when you when you do certain I've
had a little very very minor intimate
moments with women on film like and say
you do connect a little bit I can't
imagine what it's like to play
somebody's husband oh I know for the
entire season there you do develop an
intimacy it's weird it's weird that you
have that do you are you will you get
close to somebody all of a sudden you
see with their real life and it feels a
little odd at one point means sometimes
you get real close you do write real
real close yeah I guess that's common
yeah have you dated anybody that you've
worked with I think so yeah yeah yeah
you know when I was making movies back
in Sweden there's a you get even closer
it's just like the sets are more
intimate we're not so concerned with
nudity and it's just it's a little more
free-flowing oh and also I was younger
too so so it's like now I'm married you
know you have a more professional
approach to it so so the sex scenes are
a little bit more intense when you're a
younger guy and you're in sweet yeah and
it's
all the sudden you're like hey I kind of
attracted to this place when you think
you're both yeah why not I don't know
what's so different between me and a
porn actor right now those kind of
thoughts soccer some not Sweden there's
no Sox this kind of pressed up against
it yeah it's just kind of rubbing and
grinding so really is like porn movie
except because the director is like it
was a courtroom drama so real nude I
think yeah cover-up or something but no
no no it's awesome yeah you're Jim's
question like is it is there get to be a
weird thing when you develop this sort
of connection with somebody on a set and
then you kind of start to drift into
real life and you're like wait this
isn't the person that we were we were
acting like this person I don't actually
even know this person yeah but the thing
is that you like it's sort of in that
moment and and also you're in a
character and you're in this you know
circumstance so it you know it feels
really powerful at the moment and then
as soon as you take a step back you know
usually it kind of disappears and it's
also you're in a set in front of 250
people which kind of takes the intimacy
out of it so yeah you're actually trying
to create make it more intimate in that
moment and as soon as you step out it
you know it's it kind of dissipates when
did you develop did you purposely
develop an American accent thinking I
want to go to the States and act or was
that something you had to do for a role
well I mean it's it's I had no you're
one of these actors that I had no idea
had an accent yeah you should be the
wire yeah you have no idea
overseas yeah it's embarrassing like
what my dad's American so I I grew up
speaking English with my dad but I had
like a Swedish accent to it and then
when I came here I came here about eight
years ago you know they told me that I
had like a Swedish accent but but
because I grew up bilingual since birth
you know I could hear all myself like
okay that's like that's the wrong melody
so it was much easier to sort of get an
American accent and then and then I also
I went to high school here for a year I
went through in Texas oh wow
yes we in the Texas why should you lose
your father from Texas no no no that was
just random I was getting into a lot of
trouble back home and that it's just
seemed like a great getaway you know
it's not a punishment to send you to
Texas I was begging for it I was begging
for it what kind of trouble we fighting
like your big dude yeah I was mostly
getting beat up yeah I wasn't big dude
then have a chip on your shoulder that
no I had this group of friends that were
you know they sort of were on a you know
straight career path to you know they
were they all turned out to be career
criminals she was going down a bad road
yeah and but I was never like I wasn't
as tough as them and then I was trying
to sort of extract myself from them and
they did not like that so when I sort of
removed myself from them I started to
try to like hang out with other people
then you know as soon as they ran into
me with you know friends then they would
beat up my new friends we were you in a
gang it's not it wasn't like a like
there was no name or anything like that
but it was just the group you hung with
yeah exactly when Jim was a kid he was
in a he tried to start a gang with his
friends and you know what the name of
the gang it was it was the Lord it was
we were dishes show like house of cards
do you still have to audition and if you
do when you're seeing who you're up
against you like oh [ __ ] I don't have a
shot or get nervous or you just do what
you do and I don't have to audition
anymore I have not done an audition in a
while but I'm sure that there will be
projects where I have to add this and
but or you know put myself on tape or
something like that I haven't done it in
a couple of years so that's sort of the
reward you get from sort of climbing the
ladder a little some guys want you to
really I heard Woody Allen would like
everyone reads for him like it's nothing
personal it's just like Jim Carrey made
a tape to do man on the moon like their
project
and I think it's sort of as soon as you
step out of stuff that you've already
done or you know people can sort of
associate with something else that
you've done and and you you know step up
in level maybe you're hoping that you
know one of the big directors is gonna
take a shot at you you know of course
then you you'll have to do something to
show them that you're worthy sure does
it shoot your confidence or does it I I
can never just like you know I've read
that you were almost Thor and you are
almost Mad Max like or whatever you were
almost the star of Mad Max you were
almost a star of Thor both times does it
shoot your confidence to be like why
can't I get these big movies or does it
make you go like oh my god I almost got
that big movie that means I'm on the
right track here well that was kind of
interesting because those were the first
two auditions that I did in the u.s. so
I know the first audition I did was Thor
to be Thor Yeah right and and then and I
was sort of in the Final Four for that
and it didn't work out and then the
second one I did was Mad Max and and
then I went got a call back and they
said that it was sort of me and two
other guys and you know I gave it to Tom
he was good though oh he was good I mean
honestly I I like when he is when he is
on I just saw the fourth season of peaky
blinders
I haven't you got to give a couple
episodes like what Tommy's doing there
it's I mean sometimes I think that you
know he can be really big sure it's I
find him like always compelling to watch
sometimes I'm like seeing what he's
doing in a way but like when he is at
his best I can't think of anyone in like
my generation that I think is more
interesting to watch I'm like he can be
really really [ __ ] good so you know
get like weird and jealous about guys
that you look at and be like he's really
good like you can appreciate what
they're doing oh yeah yeah no I I try to
like I mean of course I feel jealous
feelings sometimes sure and and but I
really try to you know steer away from
that kind
yeah I feel a little bit when you see a
guy doing as well as he did in Mad Max
it's hard to argue why they gave to it
if you were good but I honestly get
inspired by it it's like it makes me
want to work harder and it probably
helps to like once you get house of
cards and Suicide Squad and now I mean
altered carbon is getting like all kinds
of great reviews if Friday on Netflix
available that probably puts you in a
much better
headspace in terms of like yeah I'm good
at this too sure of course that makes it
easier yeah and we gotta ask you to what
did you know obviously you're sick and
tired of talking with Kevin Spacey but
well how was it work because he's such a
great actor cloud like a great show like
we should we could just talk about house
of cards being awesome yeah now that has
to be it because obviously it's a great
project to be involved with as an artist
and creatively and whether it's when
things kind of broke were you shocked
were you shocked or were you like and I
kind of suspected I wasn't shocked
you weren't know but I mean like I had a
great work working relationship with him
you know he was very friendly to me I'll
be honest I look at you and I'm like I
get it let me ask you in general when
someone is happy that you're there let's
just say when somebody who's maybe into
you and you're not into that person in
general how do you allow them to know
I'm glad you're happy I'm here but let's
keep we're not gonna move on how do you
allow them to know this I mean I think
it's to me it's pretty simple you know
what's he what's he gonna do you know he
can't I mean I'm just I'm just being you
know I'm talking to him and I'm being
polite and I'm laughing you know it
we're if we're we're for having fun but
um you know this just did he try to get
touchy a handsy feely
no well one time when he he was like
sure we were doing this big scene and it
was a lot of a lot of extras around it
was like this big ballroom and I walked
in it was like my first scene in the day
and he'd already been shooting and he
was in the middle of changing his shirt
and and then I walked in and he was like
chill he was like very happy to see me
and and then while I walked up he was
like tucking in his shirt and then but
his you know the pants was button but
the fly was open so while he was like
tucking in he like ran his hands through
the flier and wanted to shake my hand
that way so I was like I give you a fist
bump
like that was that you weren't shocked
is it because you had heard things or
just because you're like anybody that
tries to shake your hand through their
fly is probably at something going on no
but I mean I didn't you know with Kevin
it was sort of I mean I don't want to
like get into it too much but it's like
he even heard stories you know but it's
all rumors yeah yeah who do we have that
said Jon Bernthal came on and yes
talking about and he said that he was
abusive to people Unseld I was surprised
that John said that but he goes did you
notice that was he was he he was nice to
you on baby dress yeah yeah but did you
see we were yelling at people or no no
no I mean it was perfectly professional
okay so you saw the power side no when
you said when you were like say whatever
season did you do all the White House
scenes for that season without moving to
another location or did you shoot one
one episode at a time
hold on Joe we're all that's a glitter
let us just enjoy the stunned silence of
everyone in the room if we were talking
about White House location shoes coming
in to promote where he shoots II know we
understand that we understand the gaffer
could you talk about the game
I'm going to shake his hand to fly and
you're like so hey wait till
entertainment I get the scoop about how
where yes in what order he shot the
White House location see did they do
them all of one solution understand good
good will you back that for those to
really break it
yeah was a little back and forth so
you're basically saying that they build
a set and they use it more than one day
breaking children's news they use a set
more than one day or an ongoing project
i watch the news carbon and it really is
good it deals with like the future and
downloading consciousness and things
like that yeah obviously I said first
scene do you have to be in shape at all
times because I could say you don't
audition anymore but people probably
expect that because you're in like
ridiculous shape for this thing because
he starts I don't know you saw Jim but
the opening of the show it's it back to
back to Joel being nude again it's like
he's back home but you're like you know
lately nude yeah yeah but naked butt
naked
yeah fighting by the guy like I I put
like a neon belly on this one guy and
and it's a knee on belly like balls in
mouth but like so do you do you have to
be like like I always think about it
with fighters fighters have to be in
fighting shape for you know one fight
and they work at sure but do you have to
kind of at this point you know there was
a big challenge because if you do a
movie maybe you have like one shirtless
scene and then you sort of work your way
up to that but this was a 10-month shoot
where you know it was a female
showrunner so I was like have my shirt
off and every [ __ ] you fight a guy
naked like if you have to fight a guy
naked I'm taking your much of your
orientation but if you're straight and
you have to find a guy naked does it
feel weird to be that intimately
connected to a guy or not
I mean it didn't feel weird for me but
I'm sure it felt really weird for the
person who's winning yeah I was winning
okay Joel did get himself in shape
though he's now in this show he's got
the body structure of a guy who would
fight naked like Jim if you or I fought
naked it would be horrible
being beaten up naked if 7i were naked
in a film it'll be a gang beating us up
killing us I'd be set in the shower did
you I when you when you get these
scripts do you kind of figure that this
show cuz it's tough especially on
Netflix where like the the viewer base
is gonna be like okay we've seen you on
really great stuff now you've got this
new show like you look at the script and
be like yes I know that this is going to
be one of those good shows or you just
go like let's let's roll the dice on
this one let's take a chance um no I
mean of course I'm hoping that it's
gonna be you know one of the great shows
yeah it's that thing with with
television there's always a little bit
of a gamble because usually you don't
you don't get to read all of the episode
course but um but here you know I was I
was thrilled about how this turned out
and it's also it was like the the
ambition behind it was you know kind of
unparalleled and I'm a big sci-fi nerd
yeah and I love these kind of dystopian
tales of the future and this sort of
cyberpunk aesthetic and and you know
together that was that was one of the
things that I was really excited about
the you know Netflix they come in they
give a project like this you know a
big-budget Hollywood movie kinda budget
but then at the same time it's a hard R
rating yeah you can really can portray
the sex and the violence as it is in the
book and what's great too is that like
for sci-fi we're at a place where you
can watch this show and like
realistically say like yeah that's
probably where we're going you know what
I mean we're not dealing with these like
concepts that like you really have to
stretch your imagination yeah you can
see how it happens like black mirror you
can kind of